it's incredibly lazy incredibly lazy to
say that anti-zionism or that
anti-occupation is anti-Semitic first
and foremost the Palestinians are a
Semitic people that's number one number
two
um look I'm proud of my community my
community has stood against
anti-Semitism in this country the Muslim
Community has been at the Forefront of
condemning anti-Semitism we have stood
in front of synagogues we have stood
with the Jewish Community when the
Jewish Community is attacked this is
about occupation this is a story of a
colonial entity that has driven us out
of our homes and has done so in such a
way that has forced us to try to be the
voice of a people that are being
exterminated overseas right now this is
not an anti-semitic movement this is a
pro- Freedom Movement do you think the
protests ever go too far
the protest scene is a messy scene and
so again you're going to have sometimes
that odd speaker or people get carried
away in their emotions and yes sometimes
people chant things or do things that
are contrary to the protests it's pretty
unfair when you judge the entire protest
Movement by some of these incidents that
have happened at protests and you don't
pay attention to what they're protesting
about in the first place which is a
genocide right now everything is
secondary to ending a genocide that is
ongoing in the course of this
discussion it's not an exaggeration to
say that at least 30 40 people would
have been killed just over the last few
hours because we're averaging 135 to 150
a day
so everything else is secondary to that
this is where we all need to be right
now as people of conscience how do we
stop this because every single day is
deeply
costly